hey guys there have been floating around a few leaked script pages
for the final episode of the 7th season
for quite a long time
i was suspicious about those leaked scripts
which is the main reason i didnt make a video about it earlier however
as soon as the season 7 premeire aired, its accuracy has been proven
before i introduce you to those script pages of the season finale
let me first prove to you that those particular leaks are pure truth
here is the leaked script of the
very first episode of the season which turned out to be quite accurate
as we can see every single word written on this page
we heard in the season premiere
brave men
butchered a woman pregnant with her baby
cut the throat
of a mother of five
slaughtered your guests after inviting
them into your home
but
you didnt slaughter every one of
the starks                no no
that was your mistake
you should have ripped them all out
root and stem
leave one wolf alive
and the sheep are never safe
now that we know them leaked script pages can be considered
as the truth, lets take a look at them
lets start with this page in which sansa is apparently confronting
littlefinger.... sansa says
when you brought me back to Winterfell, you told me there is no justice in the world
not unless we make it. Sansa nods to arya
there is stated that littlefinger glances at the stark girl
who now most likely knows everything about his betrayal
over her father. It also mentions a petite executioner
dagger in hand. Littlefinger is obviously
Littlefinger is obviously looking at Arya stark, the petite executioner, we can
we can elaborate the dagger is valerian steel and the dragonbone killed
that bran handed over
to arya after littlefinger gave it to him
'thankyou for all your many lessons, Lord Baelish' sansa continues
and most likely says 'i will never forget them'
rather than she will, but its not even important at that point
littlefinger tries to talk with the lady of winterfell, he says
'Sansa', but he doesnt have a chance to lie or
manipulate it, as arya swipes the dagger across his
unassuming throat. Littlefinger doesnt
see it happening until its over
it says he falls face forward to the -- at his throat
trying to keep his life. everyone in the great
hall watch him die and no one moves a muscle to help him
which is not surprising at all
Arya will kill Peter baelish with a dagger that littlefinger
held to ned starks throat while betraying him
while this dagger also partly caused the war of the 5 kings
as well as the destruction of house stark
Long story short, arya and sansa look like
showing a method of ruling which will not be anything serious
more like something sansa and jon had in the
very first episodes of the season, however upon noticing
this split between the sisters, peter baelish will take his chance
to take advantage of this certain situation by increasing
conflict between sansa and arya, which will not end as
peter baelish wants. according to leaked plot
bran stark will help his sisters
to see through littlefingers game, which will lead to sansa
sentencing baelish to death, with arya carrying out this
same sentence which matches with the leaked script
on that particular page it also says that jamie rides north
most likely looking behnd him, he's no longer in the
lannister uniform, hes no longer commanding nor representing
his house. He's dressed so as to not differ from the manner of Bronn
a sellsword... he glances at his golden hand
a hand that makes his famous all over westeros
stopping his horse he pulls on the black -- i suppose glove
specially designed for his golden hand. he notices
a single snowflake landing
this is once again confirming that in the season finale
Jamie will leave kings landing and cersi
while its also confirming that winter is coming all the way to the south
it continues, he glances back at something -- and the high towers
of the red keep -- going forward,
never looking back again, a lone horseman going north
on the kings road. I know that youre wondering what exactly will
lead jamie to finally tun his back to cersi
and where is the lone horseman heading to. i will explain it to you
additionally there is the leaked script page of him and that he'll
lead jamie to finally see what his sister and his lover
truly is. meanwhile according to leaked plot
Jamie and Bronn will secretly meet with tyrion
and davos and in this meeting they will try to convince him
to convince his brother to join him, to join what we can call it the 'good side'
but jamie is going to refuse with the statement 'he is a lannister...
and that he will never betray his house'. Well that is jamies opinion
before learning cersi's opinion of the undead army
next what is going to happen is a scene from
dragonstone in which all main characters will attend
and by the way its also confirmed
on that what we can call it meeting, 17 major characters are going to
attend which means this scene has a big role in
season 7 and the outcome of that
meeting is going to have great importance for the events to come in
season 8 considering most probably this scene
is going to be released in season 7 finale
this meeting will be organised by dany and jon
in order to show all the lords the real threat that all of them are facing
in order to unite their armies to stand a chance
against the undead army as i said there are only 2
leaked script pages from this meeting, which is only one small piece
of it, lets take a look at it its stated that
tyrion stands before his sister, cersi regards him
but not speak, tyrion sits down
cersi then says 'i suppose i should not be surprised, shes very...
much your sort of woman, a foreign whore who doesnt know her place'
Tyrion responds with 'A foreign whore who you cant...
beat or intimidate, must be hard for you'
Cersi replies 'and so you brought her here and...
her pet northener, who i suppose she convinced to bow down'
cersi is talking about dany and the pet northener
would be jon snow who supposedly
bent the knee to the mother of dragons at this point
Tyrion says 'i did not know about --
then tyrion is basically explaining to cersi how wrong she is about believing
that he has been trying to destroy their family
when it is actually quite opposite. Tyrion then says that he is the one
that prevented dany from attacking kings landing with dragons
and therefore he is the only reason cersi is still alive
Tyrion says 'dany didnt want to negotiate...
she didnt want to bring you words...
she wanted to bring you fire and blood until i advised her otherwise. if i am so comitted to destroying my family then...
why are you still here?'
'its the story youve been telling yourself since i was born...
but its not true. i dont want to destroy our family, i never have.'
in this meeting jon and dany will try to convince
all the important people that the real war is coming and that
they need to stop fighting amongst themselves
but rather unite their armies in order to stand a chance against the
night king. all the lords in power will
agree with dany and will agree to unite all their armies
upon witnessing the real threat, a captured wight
brought by jon and dany, all but cersi
cersi will not consider the situation like everyone else does
cersi will welcome the undead army. in her opinion
the white walkers along with their hoard are going to defeat
all of her enemies which would only benefit her
according to leaked plot, jamie will come to cersi and ask
permission to leave lannister army to the north
to join the great battle to join all the other armies but cersi
will refuse his request
cersi will reveal to him her opinion of the undead army
which will make jamie speechless
jamie will finally realise who his sister truly is
and it will eventually result in him turning his back on her
jamie disappointed by cersi
will leave kings landing and will be heading north
jamie will join the war between the living and the dead
he will support the living side and his experience
leading an army but it seems he is heading north alone
as it states in the leaked script page that jamie is
a lone horseman going north
it seems that he is not leading the army that i thought he would lead along
and it also seems like he is not being accompynied by his loyal friend bronn
i am rooting for jamie to prove he still has an honour
honor he sacrificed on the day he killed the mad king
honor he sacrificed in order to save hundreds of thousands of innocent lives
there is one not that important
leaked script page regarding this huge meeting
it says missandei looks up and sees a foreboding piece of the dragonpit
peeking above the foliage line
she asks 'why did they build it?' Tyrion replies
'oh it was hundreds of years ago, a long time before my time....
... ask sir jorah' jorah lets the dig slide. jorah says
'dragons dont understand the difference between whats...
something and what isnt. land, lives, children...
letting them around the city was a problem
john says
'it seems no one told --' Tyrion replies
and says something about agar targaryons 3 great dragons
(names of dragons)
then it has stated that 25 lannister guards have
rounded the --  and is headed their way, led by Bronn
Brienne and podrick are walking on their own but the
but the 3 guards on brienne
and one on pod to show they are guests of the nation
the dragon pit is located
in kings landing, and therefore a huge number or lannister guards
is not surprising. incase you dont know
dragon pit is a huge structure that housed targaryan monsters
and was seen as a giant stable for the dragons
in the season premire the dragonpit was mentioned for the very first time
in the series, and i guess it was a foreshadowing of the upcoming scenes
of great importance that will happen there
there is one more leaked script page of the season finale
this takes place in wnterfell and most probably after sansa
are orchestrated and have carried out littlefingers death
there it stated that the storm has passed
sansa and arya look out across the snowy landscape
arya looks up at her big sister. Arys asks
her sister 'are you alright?' sansa nods and replies
'its just strange, in his own horrible way...
i think he loved me' shes talking about littlefinger
and his creepy love towards her. Arya shrugs and she doesnt have any --
Arya says 'you did the right thing'
sansa replies' you did it' arya says
'im just -- you passed -- youre the lady of winterfell'
sansa glances at arya
most likely and asks for something that replies with
'nope, and im never going to be as good as you...
(probably a ruler or a lady) so i had to be good at something else'
'i never could have survived what you survived.' Sansa replies
'you would have, youre the strongest person i know' arya looks
at her big sister again. this reveals for now
and as i said at the very start of this video this leaked
pages seem to be very accurate which im actually
rooting for it to be true. not only that the starks
would finally kill a man that is among a few others
responsible for the destruction of their family
but that jamie will finally realise who his sister and lover
truly is and will finally turn his back on her
and as always let me know your opinion of this in the comments
section down below. i hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please subscribe to this channel and i hopeto see you in
the next one. peace :))))
(sorry if subs are bad its 2am and i cant type :D)